more than 24 hours later and the details
are still
jarring five experienced cyclists hit
and killed by a passing truck the
deadliest bike
car crash in southern nevada in 16 years
this happened yesterday morning on u.s
95 near searchlight
nevada highway patrol says a box truck
drifted into a group of about
20 cyclists they were on an annual ride
from the m resort looping through the
south
from boulder city to california and then
back up to henderson
a cyclist who knew many of the riders
involved says this crash
underscores the dangers they face as
they ride through southern nevada
i'm just really saddened by all this and
the more i think about it
i i really just hope that people will
pay more attention when they're out
there on the road
a vigil is planned for tomorrow at las
vegas cyclery in the southwest valley
the store's manager says his friends are
among those killed
we're a tight-knit group here in town it
affects all of us as cyclists
personally you know we're all out there
every day you know enjoying our hobby
and and trying to
you know stay alive it sounds like
everybody was doing the right thing
everybody was they had a vehicle with
them maintaining a safe
distance you know they were using lights
they were on a ride in a route that they
had used before
the driver of that box truck stayed at
the scene of the crash
nevada highway patrol says he did not
show signs of impairment